what do we do so this is where proof of
work comes in i'm sure you've heard the
term uh proof of work many times and the
whole point of proof of work is to
choose a minor at random even if one
entity tries to pretend to be a large
number of minors so how do we how do we
do it what happens is every block uh
defines a certain puzzle yeah so this is
a cryptographic puzzle um which we'll
denote by x yeah so block number n
defines puzzle x
now what is a puzzle a puzzle is
basically a problem that takes a certain
amount of work to solve yeah so let's
say
that um we'll call the solution y so y
is a solution to a puzzle and it's very
easy to verify
that if a particular y is a solution to
puzzle x
so to mine a block basically the minor
has to find the solution y that solves
the puzzle x defined by the previous
block yeah and that allows the miner to
create the next block the next block is
going to define a new puzzle x prime
that's going to have a solution y prime
and so the system continues
so how does the miner find the solution
x
well let's suppose that the density of
solutions is about 1 in 2 to the 70.
that's roughly the density in the
bitcoin proof of work system now yeah so
that means that one in two to the 70
values of y is a valid solution to the
problem
okay so how do how does a miner
find that solution basically he's going
to try lots and lots and lots of random
y's until finally he finds one y that
solves the puzzle
how does he do that well he's just going
to try over and over and over and over
and over again until he finds a y that
works and that's roughly going to take
two to the 70 tries 2 to the 70 is a
very large number yeah but basically the
the minor is going to
run basically for for enough time to try
2 to the 17 different values until he
finds a solution to the puzzle x and let
that lets him mine the the new block
okay so of course it's an assumption
that there's no faster way to find a
solution
if someone figures out a way to solve
the bitcoin puzzles faster than trying
lots of candidates at random you know
obviously they'll be able to become a
dominant minor because they'll be able
to solve to find solutions before
anybody else okay so the point here is
the first person to find the solution y
to puzzle x is the one that gets to
publish the new block and
win the mining miner rewards okay so
that's basically what we say here
that whoever finds the solution y first
publishes their block and gets the mints
the new block and gets the mining
rewards
now in some cases we might have two
people who find a solution at the same
time
that introduces a fork and i'll say that
bitcoin actually has a mechanism
to handle these forks but uh i will not
discuss that here again this is
something that we we we cover at great
length in our blockchain classes
okay good
um so we already said that the miner who
finds the solution y is the one that
mints the new block and therefore wins
the mining reward so in bitcoin the
mining reward is 12 and a half bitcoin
in ethereum the mining reward is five
ethers and so on and so forth so
generally in a proof of work system the
miner who actually finds the solution
makes a lot of money from finding that
solution okay good so interestingly the
probability of actually finding the
solution is proportional to how much
computing computing power you have yeah
so
if you have a lot of computing power and
you can always find the solution that
means before everybody else that means
you'll earn 12 and a half bitcoins every
10 minutes and just so you realize that
translates today to around 90 000
every 10 minutes yes that's basically
what uh the maximum amount that a miner
can make if they're able to find a
solution every time
well so the fact that this is how much
money they can make every 10 minutes
puts an upper bound on the amount of
power that that economically makes sense
to spend in finding a solution why
and so if you just put this um together
so just look at the price of power so 90
000
every 10 minutes it translates to about
18 terawatt hours of energy at any given
time so this is the maximum amount of
energy that economically makes sense to
use for proof of work if you're still
going to be making money from from
mining and that applies to the whole
ecosystem as a whole of course miners
are not even close to spending this much
energy for finding solutions but this is
in some sense a theoretical
maximum
nevertheless it's kind of interesting
just as a kind of as a funny anecdote
it's kind of interesting that if you
look at how much the country of ireland
may how much energy the country of
ireland makes well they make about uh 26
terror hours um at any given time and so
it's kind of interesting that the
maximum theoretical amount of energy
that makes sense in a bitcoin network
is basically comparable to what the
entire entire country makes now again
this is actually incorrect it's not
true that the bitcoin network actually
spends this amount of energy to um to
find the solution why this is just a
theoretical maximum
nevertheless uh we know that there's
actually quite a lot of energy being
spent to find these y's because there's
competition among miners to be the first
to find the y and the more computing
power you have the more likely you are
to find it and to find that why and get
the mining reward as a result so there's
a lot of competition a lot of energy
being spent at finding these solutions
and really uh there's not a lot of
benefit to that energy other than
creating these new blocks
okay good so that's what uh proof of
work is the reason uh it prevents
presumably prevents these civil civil
attacks is um if you're gonna
say that you can control many minors
that's gonna be expensive for you
because you are going to incur quite
high costs in the power that your
hardware is going to demand yeah so
controlling many miners is not that easy
so that was the idea that would lead to
presumably decentralization of the
mining infrastructure
in reality unfortunately that hasn't
quite happened and so if you look at
blockchain.com they will tell you the
distribution of miners for different
blocks so for every block we can
identify the miner that mined that block
right that's the miner that gets paid at
the coin base
and so we identify the miners and we can
look at a particular
24-hour window to see who mined the most
blocks and so you can see that um you
know btc.com mined around twenty percent
of all blocks and pool mined around
fourteen percent of all blocks and so on
and so forth if you sum up the top four
you'll see that together they uh control
about 55 of the bitcoin mining power
which means that every other block is uh
mined by one of these four yeah so in
reality there's actually quite a lot of
centralization
um of the mining power which is kind of
a problem with uh the proof of work
system
okay i should say though
that uh consensus protocols and proof of
work is a fascinating and extremely
interesting topic there are lots and
lots and lots of attacks and lots and
lots of um game theoretic
issues around around mining how to
distribute rewards and so on um it's a
fascinating and long and large topic
which i won't be able to uh cover here
unfortunately um
but again we this is something that we
cover quite extensively in our courses
if you want to learn a little bit more
about proof of work and the issues with
proof of work
there are beautiful attacks that are
kind of interesting to look up so i
would suggest looking up an attack
called selfish mining an attack called
feather forking um and many others and
so you can just look for those terms and
and read a little about
issues with proof of work and attacks on
proof of work
on your own
however i have to say that because of
the energy expenditure with proof of
work and also the fact that it doesn't
quite lead to decentralization
the more modern projects are moving away
from proof of work and eventually proof
of work actually might be phased out so
just to give you an idea for what's
coming to replace proof of work because
we still
we still try to pick uh generally
speaking try to pick minors at random
and we try to do it in a way that's
sybil resistant
and so two ideas that have come have
come up is one called proof of space
where the idea here is rather than
choosing a minor proportional to how
much computing power that miner has we
instead choose a minor proportional to
how much disk space that miner has so
this encourages people to use their
disks to win uh you know to win the
mining rewards but discs aren't very are
energy efficient so it's not going to be
it's not going to require a lot of power
to actually compete in this in this
environment all you need is a lot of
disk space which presumably you already
have for other reasons yeah so there's a
blockchain being created that uses proof
of space in proof instead of proof of
work another idea which is uh very
popular and many blockchains actually
use is what's called proof of stake
where again instead of
committing to resources like computing
power or space instead the miners put up
collateral which we call stake so they
use coins themselves that they bought as
collateral for behaving honestly and
then if they ever misbehave they're
penalized in some way for example in the
ethereum network there's a proposal um
to basically uh what what's called
slashing where
misbehaving miners will actually lose
some of their stake yeah and there are
many examples of proof of stake systems
i just listed a few here if you want to
read a little bit about how these proof
of stake systems work it's still a very
complicated
concept to get right
there are a lot of ways to design a
proof of stake system that would be in a
non-stable equilibrium
that might actually
become unstable
and so this is actually a fascinating
area still an area of research
but as you can see there are already
experiments in place that are
experimenting with proof of stake so no
energy being wasted here um
and instead we use uh we use uh stake
to choose the miners and finally i'll
mention there's another approach called
quorum systems where instead of choosing
miners at random basically we say we
designate miners that we trust
and essentially new blocks are issued by
a quorum of miners you can imagine maybe
you know 20 miners that are distributed
all over the world perhaps run by large
banks large reputable banks we just
happen to trust them to run the
blockchain correctly and if they do
then they're the ones who are allowed to
issue blocks and there are a couple of
systems in that paradigm stellar is a
good example
and so again no energy being wasted here
it's basically the blockchain is being
managed by a collection of miners that
the users decide to trust
okay so that's another example of a
consensus system okay good so that's
what i wanted to say about consensus
mechanisms and so we're almost done uh
in the next segment i'll just tell you a
few final thoughts and then we'll
conclude